[Music]
how does a person get to be a Disney
cast member at the happiest place on
earth we uncovered 10 strange
requirements that may surprise you watch
until the end to see what cast members
are required to say to difficult and
rude customers it's pretty hilarious new
here subscribe to the things channel to
get our latest videos if you love Disney
theme parks as much as we do click on
the thumbs up button below now check out
these 10 strange requirements to become
a cast member at Disney theme parks they
must know everything did you know that
Disney theme park cast members are not
allowed to say the phrase I don't know
it's true if a guest asks the cast
member question they are forbidden to
utter the words I don't know instead
cast members must find a way to answer
the question they can do this by asking
other cast members or searching until
they find an answer the intention behind
this is to make sure guests are never
lost and wandering aimlessly it was
important to Walt Disney that all guests
be treated like royalty think of it if
the Queen of Hearts and Alice in
Wonderland asked a question and heard I
don't know as a response it would be off
with his head
Walt Disney was a pretty strict guide
but that diligence has resulted in the
most magical places and adventures on
earth this makes us want to find really
hard questions to ask the cast members
in the park like why is the sky blue
what's the square root of 69,000 169 how
many jellybeans are in this jar if you
answered I don't know to any of these
questions you may not be the right
candidate for the job of a Disney theme
park cast member no tattoos allowed this
is actually a pretty common job
requirement for certain types of gigs
but you would think Disney would want a
few tattooed cast members to play
swashbuckling pirates there are so many
creative types working for Disney there
have got to be a lot of covered up
tattoos around the theme parks but we
checked and on the Disney intern blog
there are strict requirements about
tattoos it states very clearly that
visible tattoos are not permitted for
costumed or non costumed cast members it
explained
that tattoos must be discretely and
completely covered at all times it goes
even further with strict rules about how
to cover up tattoos it states that the
only methods permitted to conceal
tattoos are clothing or makeup based on
the role of the cast member makeup may
not be permitted at all the rules say
that would makeup is born it should be
natural-looking so the tattoo and makeup
are not noticeable cast members are
expected to wear long sleeve undershirts
under their uniforms to cover arm
tattoos not ideal for the summer months
but if you want to work at Disneyland or
Disney World
it's what you've got to do sure it makes
sense it would be weird to see
Cinderella with a big tattoo on her arm
turn that frown upside down if you're a
cast member at Disney theme parks you'd
better be ready to smile no matter what
that's because when you're on the clock
and in front of the guests
frowning is absolutely forbidden it
doesn't matter how hot it is how tired a
cast member may be and how they wish
they were riding the rides instead of
working there is to be no frowning none
zilch
imagine having to smile and the hot Sun
all day long no matter what well there
are some exceptions if the cast member
is playing a villain then scowling and
growling is permitted but in that fun
Disney way which is probably not very
satisfying if you're in a bad mood it's
the happiest place on earth it makes
sense that guests wouldn't want to see
their favorite princess with a big old
pad on her face it would ruin the magic
don't you think so if you want to work
for a Disney theme park might we suggest
that you practice your smile in the
mirror for Oh about eight hours just to
get an idea of what it would be like if
you were working at the park and put
that frown away you won't be needing it
for a while Prince is training and
grooming Disney princesses are just one
type of what they call a face character
at the theme parks the term face
character refers to any character who
wears makeup and shows his or her face
rather than a costume with a giant head
many of these face character actors have
already had years of dance training such
as tap jazz and ballet they also have
considerable acting skills characters
with an accent like Mary Poppins windy
or Alice have to take a full day of
dialect training to get the accents just
right the character's voices are
oftentimes high
than the actors normal speaking voice so
some actors have to go on vocal rest to
give their vocal cords some time to heal
after a long day speaking in a
character's voice then there's the
grooming part when an actress who plays
a Disney Princess arrived to work she is
put in a makeup chair where a
professional cosmetologist does her
makeup and fits her for a wig some
actresses play more than one character
so they may need to change it out during
their shifts the wigs and costumes are
kept there and cleaned and styled every
couple of days Veta princess is a lot of
work
no smoking chewing gum pointing or
breaking character if you haven't
figured it out by now
Disney has a lot of very strict rules in
place to keep the magic alive in the
Magic Kingdom it seems obvious that the
cast members are not allowed to smoke
and it's really a no-brainer that they
wouldn't be allowed to chew gum in fact
there is no gum even sold anywhere in
the park not anywhere that's because
when people spit their gum on the
sidewalk it makes dark marks on the
sparkling pavement it's very difficult
to clean up and kind of ruins the
polished look and feel of the park but
here is a strange role cast members are
not allowed to point with their index
finger they are required to use two
fingers when giving directions there are
a couple of reasons for this rule in
other countries it's considered very
offensive when people point with their
index finger also many people talk about
the fact that Walt always used to point
with two fingers so it's kind of a
tribute to mr. Walt Disney himself the
next time you visit Disneyland or Disney
World
watch the cast members and you'll see
for yourself they call this the Disney
point they are also not allowed to break
character not ever all character cast
members must undergo an intense audition
process if you want to audition for the
role of Disney theme park characters get
ready to spend the whole day auditioning
according to a recruiter for the Disney
College Program hopefuls should plan on
spending 1 to 6 hours on the audition
process the first round of cuts is based
on the height of the actors then they
have the remaining candidates do a bunch
of improv exercises one potential
employee was asked to pretend to be a or
then Winnie the Pooh and even
pregnant cheerleader that's a pretty
strange request don't you think more
cuts are made during the improv portion
of the auditions then there would be
face characters are asked to line up so
the recruiters and judges can see how
much they look like the actual Disney
characters they are asked to smile if
they don't fit the right look
they are dismissed after that the
candidates must learn a combination of
dance steps in what they call the
animation process of the auditions then
they are sent to hair and makeup after
they adjust in their wigs and costumes
they are coached on what each of their
characters should sound like they must
read a small script imitating the
characters voice and dialects if they
pass all that they get the job signature
training during the training process
Disney character cast members are
required to watch the movies and shows
of the characters they will be
portraying to learn how they move and
speak then they have to practice making
the same movements vocal patterns and
dialects and mannerisms once they have
all the movement and vocal training
nailed down they have another
interesting training they must go
through its called signature training if
you've been to the theme parks chances
are you've seen kids walking around with
autograph books and you've probably seen
the character signing these autograph
books well they are not allowed to just
sign any old way each character has
their own unique signature that the
performers must learn and master before
signing their first autographs there are
strategic designs that are applied to
each character's signature for instance
Pluto's signature makes a dog call out
of the O in his name Minnie Mouse dots
her eyes with hearts the Mad Hatter
draws a little hat in the signature and
I bet all of us know the classic
handwriting of our pal Mickey Mouse
imagine how hard it might be to sign
anything well in those big furry
costumes kudos to you Disney cast
members cast members must be able to
think on their feet there are pro and
cons to being a fairy character versus a
face character face characters don't
have to sweat it out in those heavy
costumes and they're allowed to talk and
sing but very characters are not allowed
to use their voices at all they are not
allowed to talk or sing you may have
heard them make a kissing sound when
they blow kisses to guests but that's
about the extent of the noise they are
allowed to make with their mouths
bass characters have challenges that are
a little different yes they get to
interact with kids without that big head
in the way but they really have to think
on their feet many curious kids have
difficult questions and they expect
their favorite Disney characters to have
answers and you remember the rule that
they're not allowed to say I don't know
right then there are the more awkward
moments like when kids learned at school
that Pocahontas passed away a long time
ago yet she is standing right in front
of a bunch of kids at Disney World
apparently during a meet-and-greet with
the Native American princess a little
British kid walked up to the Pocahontas
character and said that his class just
visited her grave last year awkward
magical trash pickup in order to keep
your job as a cast member at Disney's
theme parks you must be prepared to pick
up any trash you see on the ground at
all times the happiest place on earth
cannot have dirty streets but you
mustn't pick up like a typical peasant
would oh no there is a technique that is
taught to cast members for picking up
trash rather than just stooping or
squatting down to grab an old churro
wrapper the cast member must do what is
called a graceful swoop and scoop motion
we are wondering how much of their
training is dedicated to this maneuver
there is also another rule that cast
members must stay immersed in all things
Disney while at work in the park of
course they must stay in character all
times when visible to the public eye but
according to Business Insider they are
also not allowed to make any references
to pop culture that exists outside the
Disney universe so that means no
discussions about the NFL or the
Kardashians unless it's in the world of
Disney cast members can't talk about it
while working in the parks everything
that the cast does and says must be
graceful magical and exists only within
the realm of Disney secret codes one
major requirement to work as a cast
member at Disney theme parks is to use
secret codes cast members have to be
very careful when communicating with
each other this is also kept to the
magic alive inside the kingdom walls for
example Disney cast members are not
allowed to say that they play certain
characters this would destroy the
fantasy instead the cast members are
only allowed to say that they are
friends with that particular character
or that they hung out with that
character sin
it's a matter of cleaning up unpleasant
messes if a child gets sick on a ride or
has an accidents the cast members use
the phrase code B you can probably guess
what the V stands for and sometimes kids
get separated from their families when a
cast member encounters this problem they
say they have a lost adult whom they
must find this is apparently for safety
reasons so you'll never hear a cast
member say lost child when a cast member
has had their fill with a difficult
guest they'll say the phrase have a
Disney day that might be the nicest way
we've ever heard to give someone a piece
of your mind and those are the 10
strange requirements to become a cast
member at Disney theme parks we hope you
enjoyed this video thanks for watching
[Music]